[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la commanderie
d'elancourt avec ma photo est pas doué
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes une
artiste pluridisciplinaire artiste
plasticienne scénographe fondatrice et
directrice artistique et de la compagnie
mobilis immobilisme et vous travaillez à
versailles
tout d'abord d'où est venue votre envie
d'être artiste je n'ai pas choisi depuis
tout petit en fait je crée je dessine je
mets en scène c'était une évidence et
j'ai eu la chance de pas faire de choix
justement et mes parents l'ont vu tout
de suite donc voilà j'ai suivi ma route
artistique avec des études artistiques
et que les beaux-arts le théâtre la
peinture tout s'est mélangé et donc vous
avez créé la compagnie mobilis
immobiliste c'est une compagnie
pluridisciplinaire qui permet la
création à travers le numérique le
spectacle vivant les arts plastiques et
l'audiovisuel
qu'est ce que ça apporte de croiser tout
cela m'a beaucoup de richesses moi c'est
vrai que j'ai commencé par le théâtre la
peinture et je me suis je me suis senti
seul très vite devant une toile a exposé
dans des galeries etc et je faisais du
théâtre par ailleurs dont j'avais cette
expérience du spectacle vivant donc une
communication avec les autres et j'ai
vraiment eu envie de rassembler ces
disciplines le spectacle vivant
travaillant troupes
assemblez les compétences et puis le
numérique est arrivé comme ça comme une
découverte sur mon parcours et qui m'a
permis de créer de la magie surtout de
travailler que des gens complètement
différents programmateur scientifique et
j'ai toujours une passion pour ces
rencontres en fait la relation cela m'a
toujours passionné fan de léonard de
vinci et terrain voilà c'était vraiment
ne plus être seul travailler en équipe
et apprendre apprendre des autres et
s'enrichir les uns les autres
est ce que le numérique pardon permet de
viser un autre public
je crois oui alors c'est vrai que moi
pour moi j'ai remplacé les outils
numériques qui était que des outils
contemporains par mes pinceaux et
c'était vraiment créer de la magie
pouvoir faire bouger des choses à
distance avoir une perception de
l'espace sonore en partant toujours du
corps si j'ai appelé la compagnie
moglice mobilis tu es vraiment le
mouvement à la vie c'est le mouvement
voilà une présence une présence au coeur
à chaque fois des créations qui
interagit avec des environnements
visuels sonores interactif et ça m'a
permis cette magie là cette interaction
qui m'a tout de suite intéressé et donc
vous avez fait les cours florent
j'ai fait les cours florent c'était une
très belle expérience je n'étais pas
enfin je faisais du théâtre comme ça un
matin au lycée mais j'ai été arrêté en
fait dans la rue à la villette par
monsieur flanc et donc j'ai été
intriguée et j'ai accepté de suivre son
stage cinéma et j'ai été embarqué dans
l'école comme ça parce que et c'était
extrêmement intéressant de d'avoir ces
notions de plateau de travailler
ensemble de répétition
donc oui ça m'a beaucoup riches c'est à
quel moment de votre carrière c'était au
début c'est vraiment au début je sortais
j'ai passé un bac arts plastiques et
j'ai je peignais déjà j'exposais déjà
dès 16 ans en fait à paris dans des
centres culturels et s'évader des
galeries et et voilà je crois que c'est
au salon de l'étudiant j'ai rencontré
monsieur plan et donc c'était vraiment
j'avais 21 ans
quelque chose comme ça et vous vous
dites que l'art vous vient de l'enfance
est ce que votre famille aussi est dans
l'art pas du tout mais j'avais quand
même de grands pères qui dessinent et
sculpté par plaisir et qui m'emmenait
dans les expositions l'une a même un qui
m'accompagne partout qui était mon
premier mécène à m'acheter aussi mes
premières toiles donc j'ai été
accompagné par ses deux figures quand
même importante mais avec un père aussi
qui dessine très très bien mais qui a
gardé ça en loisir vous avez la fibre
familiale de la qualité je sais pas mais
en tout cas le dessin oui il ya quelque
chose quand même qui s'est transmis au
niveau de la main et du défunt d'accord
et donc vous proposer aussi des ateliers
vous êtes dans deux projets avec des
classes à magny les hameaux et à
versailles
amani vous êtes en charge du pro du
projet livres 1 fille donc c'est le
numéro 17
avec deux classes primaires en quoi ça
consiste alors j'ai découvert ce projet
je trouve ça très très joli c'est un un
livre papier a réalisé avec donc deux
classes pour moi cette année avec donc
un artiste intervenants choisis on m'a
choisi cette année parce que j'étais
spécialisé en art numérique c'est un peu
leur désir de cette année de faire
travailler les enfants avec leurs
nouvelles tablettes et surtout aussi
abordé ce projet de façon
pluridisciplinaire donc le cahier des
charges c'est un livre papier
à la taille de la pierre tombale
manquantes du monument aux morts donc
c'est vraiment un travail sur la mémoire
et le nom d'oubli de ces gens à manier
la mort pour la france souhaitait porter
et j'ai trouvé très jolie en cette
période très particulière de faire
travailler les enfants sur cet état de
guerre puisque on l'a vraiment entendu
beaucoup cette année et sur quelque
chose de très positif donc du coup les
enfants n'ont tiré vraiment trois thèmes
la fraternité la mémoire et la paix et
on a travaillé à la fois puisque c'était
un peu aussi mon domaine le corps dans
l'espace dans un dispositif multimédia
autour de ces thèmes là je les ai filmé
donc ça va être un petit théâtre virtuel
qui va faire partie de cette boîte du
livre infinie et aussi donc là je suis
en contact avec un éditeur imprimeur
pour faire imprimer les images créées en
duo par les enfants sur des tablettes et
qui correspondent à l'écriture de leurs
textes donc ça sera remis le 8 mai très
lors de la cérémonie normalement
j'espère et à versailles aussi du coup
vous proposer des ateliers de danse ici
encore avec deux classes de primaire
quel est le but que ce que vous y faites
alors j'ai mis en place s'avèrent c'est
que ça n'existait pas depuis cinq ans
pareil j'ai en résidence à versailles
dans un espace très chaud en fait y est
un lieu culturel ou ce qu'on sont
programmés des expositions voilà
sûrement assez long de l'exposition des
belles expositions
j'ai voulu proposer à la ville en fait
cette intervention danse à l'école que
je fais depuis 15 ans
en ile-de-france et mais peut-être
martin ma particularité c'est de lier la
danse à d'autres domaines
donc les arts visuels la photographie la
sculpture voilà donc on a abordé selon
la programmation de la ville et des
lieux culturels la danse sous des
aspects voilà un peu particulier pour
faire aussi des réseaux sur le
territoire et sur la ville de visites
d'expositions en lien etc et on a une
très belle maintenant participation du
théâtre montansier qui permet aux
enfants d'être valorisé présenté le
projet sur scène
qui voit là qu'est le beau point final
de ce projet là donc c'était aborder la
danse de création avec les enfants c'est
à dire qu'à des enfants qui se développe
vraiment dans des projets comme ça qui
se valorisent et qui s'extériorise alors
qu en classe on va peut être trouver des
enfants très timide et réservé et enfin
les maîtresses comme voilà tous les
participants du projet voit chaque fois
quelque chose n'est pas nous hissant et
moi je suis toujours très très ému de
voir sur scène parce qu'on arrive à des
choses avec eux extraordinaire et c'est
pas de la danse contemporaine et
technique on part vraiment de la
création l'imaginaire de l'enfant donc
moi ça m'apporte beaucoup dans les
échanges avec eux et puis je suis là
vraiment pour coordonner toutes leurs
propositions et arriver à créer quelque
chose de construit donc
il ya le travail de mémoire aussi de
répétition construction et d'être
ensemble de faire ensemble parce qu'il y
en a un qui est semée sur le côté non ça
va plus quoi donc voilà ça beaucoup de
valeur à travers ce projet là qui me
plaisent et qui sont véhiculés en fête
est toujours à versailles donc votre
compagnie elle est soutenue par la ville
de versailles vous y est en résidence
depuis cinq ans quels sont les gros
projets que vous avez fait là bas en
plus du coup alors la première rencontre
avec l'équipe culturelle de versailles
c'était j'étais invitée pour la nuit la
création la première nuit de création où
était invité un artiste extérieur
d'habitude c'était les élèves de l'école
des beaux-arts et c'est donc là j'ai été
d'un seul confronté à des grands lieux
l'école des beaux-arts il était central
a été pareil hein prises pour le
numérique avec des projections géantes
interactif sur les murs et puis après
ben régulièrement chaque année on m'a
demandé de faire des propositions donc
j'ai fait deux propositions musée
lambinet sur des années différentes une
en intérieur une installation
interactive en regard de leurs
collections
une autre fois c'était convenu de la
création en extérieur avec des comédiens
du conservatoire du théâtre plus des
musiciens un quartet versailles et voilà
c'était toujours essayé de recréer du
lien avec des personnalités de la ville
et je suis intervenu pour les nuits du
patrimoine haussier à l'atelier
numérique avec des installations aussi
fallait régulièrement selon là selon les
événements en fête est donc ici nous
sommes à la commanderie d'elancourt à
partir du 5 avril et jusqu'au mois
d'octobre vous proposer une exposition
en extérieur qui s'appelle à la lisière
c'est un lieu qui vous parle la
commanderie oui moi je les ai découverts
vraiment la première fois quand
mais invitée à habiter la chapelle avec
des installations numériques sur le
corps en mouvement
et puis on m'a fait la proposition
pendant un an de rester en résidence ici
et c'est vraiment cette installation
c'est vraiment le constat de ce que de
ce que j'ai vu est ici en vivant ici
c'est à dire c'est un lieu contemplatif
où toutes sortes de personnes venaient
s'asseoir et je me suis en observant
aussi c'était temps je me suis aperçu
qu'il y avait une faune des insectes le
héron il y avait toute une vie en fait
que si on ne prêtait pas attention ne la
voyait pas et j'ai voulu mettre voilà un
point d'orgue sur sept vies minuscules
existantes et et le développer une
imagerie poétique pour donner à regarder
le lieu autrement voilà donc c'est oui
ce lieu m'inspire moi je pense que
l'histoire aussi les pierres alors oui
eh bien c'est un lieu un peu rêvé pour
des artistes d'être de créer ici est
donc cette exposition rapidement
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra voir ici oui
alors vous verrez si c'est un descriptif
donc vous verrez si porte rouge
entrouverte
voilà pour recréer un espace intérieur
extérieur et ses portes sont des portes
vitrées sur lesquels j'ai gravées en
fait donc deux couleurs différentes sur
lesquels j'ai gravé justement les
animaux ou les ancêtres que j'ai pu
observer comme des planches d'histoire
naturelle mais il ya des intrus s'est
découvert une sirène voilà des choses
comme ça ça c'était côté un petit peu
d'humour est anecdotique mais aussi du
coup dans les temps donc y avoir 15 donc
à 15 gravure mais y avoir 15 bambou
rouge clignotant donc c'était vraiment
comme des petits sentiment qui montre
ses présente existantes et qu'on pourra
regarder dans laxe en fait des gravures
pour montrer que là ça existe c'est la
même si on ne les voit pas c'est là et
le cahier des charges c'était que ça se
voit aussi la nuit donc du coup il y
avait toute cette technique a développé
avec pas d'électricité donc garder
lumière pendant six mois en extérieur
donc et tout une alimentation avec
panneau solaire batterie autonome et
c'est donc voilà les temps sera aussi
habité
et peut-être des futurs perchoir aux
oiseaux je ne sais pas pourquoi le
découvrir mon as tu es donc vous êtes
sur un autre gros projet à la verticale
de soi qui est un projet de danse en
lien avec des personnes à mobilité
réduite
en quoi ça consiste c'était vraiment le
désir d'un coup c'était un constat en
fait en rencontrant une danseuse en
fauteuil de 2,2 faire autrement de
donner plus d'autonomie nous mobilité à
ces personnes en fauteuil qui exerçait
la danse avec déjà des fauteuils
technologique mais il s'avère que sur ma
sur ma route à l'issue d'une conférence
où j'intervenais où intervenait cette
danseuse est un chercheur en nouvelles
mobilités robotique
on s'est dit qu'il y avait quelque chose
à créer ensemble et on est parti dans
deux prototypes innovants
c'est à dire pour gagner de la mobilité
donc avoir une liberté des bras tout est
géré par l'inclinaison du corps avoir
une extrême légèreté une extrême
transparence et en même temps une
élévation du corps ça c'est un premier
prototype est le deuxième est développé
en france et au japon va falloir qu'on
les rapatrie mais c'est vraiment une
structure comme une crinoline truffé de
capteurs qui s'articule qui permet de
tenir debout et de pouvoir faire aussi
des choses extraordinaires avoir des
angles du corps
inhabituel donc et puis à long terme
avec ce cette université qui est à
vélizy le laboratoire a dit svc de faire
un centre
ils sont déjà centre ressource en
nouvelles mobilités une plateforme en
fait d'un islam on l'appelle avec des
nouveaux outils innovants ouvert à tous
vraiment l'idée aussi c'est d'ouvrir nos
savoirs tout soit en open source et
utilisable par tous donc danseurs mais
aussi non danseurs parce qu'il ya des
gens qui aiment la sensation de glisse
et c'est donc c'est un projet ambitieux
commencé déjà depuis trois ans qu'est la
recherche est longue il ya un brevet en
cours etc
donc voila apres bien merci beaucoup
merci parce doué merci à vous et merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette émission se
retrouve bientôt dans un nouveau vide
mais